Should are there any programs that are the right that a person should not run?
Well, I've always said you have to be careful with the bacterial programs and really
the Lyme program. So the Lyme Burelia program, you have to be careful
runny that because you could liberate because Burelia of Burgodorphy, the main culprit in
Lyme disease is a gram-negative bacteria and gram-negative bacteria have Lyme of polysaccharides
in their cell membranes. If you kill them quickly which you can do, runny the Burelia program,
you'll liberate a lot of Lyme of polysaccharides and you'll get side effects from that
called Herximer action. That would be the only thing that I'd say be careful runny would be
the Lyme program. Not wrong with running it, but I'd say don't run it but go slow at that and see
how you react to it because some people may have Lyme and don't know it at all. I'll run this Lyme
program and they get sick afterwards. That's a sign that you may have Lyme if you got sick after it
and you need to run it but maybe you need to go slow with it.